[Music]
I do whatever are not doing this yeah
he's already you just comes in
[Music]
and he hits
I'm not going
or is this going give me that happening
source is going here then I mean it your
grandpa
[Music]
okay let's try it
they owe her I love it
and then her body hits
[Music]
that's fate
don't do it we gotta push me or not
[Music]
this cell phone is not freaking him it's
it's following not personal balance is
here did not follow that so I keep
connection move out of the way you see
my hunts don't spread your plane
[Music]
there's a cute projection the art is not
a free-for-all we're now micro drilling
okay so I'm going to bring my arms in
[Music]
arms end easy like a sword up goes the
hand the thumb it's turning the elbow
starts to push and I pass his elbow to
my other half
by me
[Music]
so not like this too late
not like this mess together I'm not
lifting his elbow team this sound is
lifting his elbow his hands pity
[Music]
okay let's try this that part okay so
that that's the movement I'm doing here
don't take pressure off by doing that
lets him hit your face he hits this spot
right there push on it this is what he
gets this far then his elbow get like
that's when I manipulated by following
it and turning it as it goes down
[Music]
I'm not gonna like this yeah it's the
way I'm kidding myself
so he will get light oh not just moving
just don't disconnect - they got me you
got me
you see stay with him
[Music]
and no point am I making this armor and
just following this hole right there
that just created
then he has energy so I go round it
[Music]
there's his energy I go wrong all right
hey remember I said he had to entertain
that's why I went around kazoo she
should already happen on the first note
yeah so when she comes in it's already
like she has no energy so I'm not I'm
not interested in making her phone okay
she had energy I can't do extension I
can't do that so I get and press into it
and then I go wrong so we'll have them
have no energy no energy and we'll just
go on and we'll take
so no energy up you though we can do
this joke and the last pot either one of
us boom in take it right in turn all the
way into the mouth so that should be my
attention because there's the in space
he's going to top me yes Hey
so please stop being me and that's where
I might roll around there's a katfoe not
that's not where I take them down here's
the rate loses balance yeah I'm gonna
tell you and I come around so I feel the
energy feel the energy I understand
where the in space is not I want to hear
that filled up and practice going around
it so you can't just die at the bottom
[Music]
hey let's go she's so old
episode 26 I gave you a more popular
definition of negative concept so this
helped you that's taking your balance it
is not what it is it's not everything
else Mina so I I'm not throwing the
elbow I'm not leaving get it so I can do
it
[Music]
so what I'm trying to show you is I'm
not using the elbow sidekick elbow by
the way I'm not leaning I stood up
straight I'm also not using any this as
I went down the way you get it so it's
gotta be something else okay you can you
can do all those things you see Eileen
and I had the elbow but it wasn't what I
was doing so you have to watch that
you're not doing those things okay even
if you see me because I'm really not and
the way you tell this house I'm sure he
likes and if you break it won't be able
to do that because this pin in your feet
you have to wait for her way to get off
of you you get that okay so let's just
work on the first car
[Music]
to that micro drilling the first part